imagine you're considering investing
into a t it's not a flashy stock like
tesla or apple but it's one of the
oldest and most established companies in
america they pay a phenomenal dividend
yield of 8.34 percent and the man
running the company grew it from being
just a small phone company to being a
telecommunications giant
most would agree that such an investment
would be quite safe you may not make
millions but the chances of you losing
money are quite low
now what if it was revealed that at t
had been faking their financials for
years in the magnitude of billions
what if they were secretly taking out
new loans to pay off all the debt and
the entire front of atm t was just a
facade at first glance such a massive
fraud may seem impossible to pull off
yet that's exactly what took place about
two decades ago with a company called
worldcom after a peak worldcom employed
80 000 employees and boasted a market
cap of 180 billion dollars which is 2
billion more than what att is worth
today
despite their massive size the entire
company would go bankrupt just one month
after being exposed
so here's how bernard eppers ran the
largest accounting scandal in u.s
history
taking a look back bernard evers was
born on august 27 1941 in edmonton
alberta his birthplace likely didn't
mean much to him though as his family
was constantly moving around canada and
america his father was a traveling
salesman so his job required him to
consistently target new markets and
customers despite the hectic nature of
their lives though the eber's family was
devout christians they tried their best
to steal christian values into all of
their children but unfortunately it
doesn't look like they were successful
with bernard on the bright side it looks
like the family was finally able to
settle down in canada when bernard was a
teenager and this is where bernard would
attend high school and college
it's not clear how bernard performed
academically but he was a star performer
when it came to basketball after high
school bernard would initially attend
the university of alberta and calvin
college before switching over to
mississippi college on a basketball
scholarship unfortunately though bernard
would get injured before his senior year
in college so he would be tasked with
coaching the junior varsity team instead
of playing though bernard was
disappointed by the turn of events he
actually really liked coaching and he
says that coaching played a massive role
in his rise to the top
anyway bernard graduated with a
bachelor's degree in physical education
and a minor in secondary education in
1967 after college bernard worked a
bunch of odd jobs for a few years each
this included being a high school pe
teacher a basketball coach a garment
warehouse manager and even a bouncer but
by 1974 burner decided to do something
more long-term and that led him to the
motel industry bernard started off by
purchasing a small motel in colonel
mississippi two years later he would
bring on some investors which allowed
him to quickly expand his motel
operation to 9 best westerns by the end
of the 1970s
on paper burner's net worth was
skyrocketing as he paid off the
properties
but in terms of cash it was a different
story the motel chain was profitable but
it didn't produce very much in terms of
cash flow so bernard started looking for
some more lucrative opportunities and
that's when atnp would be divested
the department of justice had been
assessing the att monopoly since 1974
and they had finally come to a decision
in 1982 they announced that at t must
split up and relinquish control of the
bell operating companies
this resulted in a dnt splitting up into
eight different companies with only one
of them carrying on the atnt name
ironically at t would end up buying back
half of these companies and the other
half would turn into verizon so this
wasn't all that effective in breaking up
the monopoly
but right after the divester it seemed
like telecommunication industry had
finally opened up for disruption hopeful
entrepreneurs flooded the space and one
of these hopefuls was bernard and his
friends
in 1983 bernard and three of his friends
borrowed five hundred thousand dollars
against their properties and purchased a
struggling phone company they named the
company ldds or long distance discount
service and with that they had entered
the telecommunications industry
initially burner tried to play a passive
role by simply being an investor but the
thing to keep in mind is that this was a
struggling phone company and that wasn't
an accident
the original management was terrible and
the new management they hired wasn't
that much better so the investors got
together and decided to check a
management once again
they appointed bernard as the new ceo
despite his lack of experience
bernard was actually very transparent
that he didn't have any of the skills of
regular businessmen he admitted that he
wasn't an engineer or an accountant but
what he was was a coach
bernard approached a job as being a
coach for employees and this approach
actually worked extremely well
just six months after taking over as ceo
ldds became profitable and the bernard
could finally focus on growing the
company initially he attempted to grow
the company the natural way
in november of 1983 ldds got its
long-distance carrier certification and
their first long-distance customer was
the university of southern mississippi
but it didn't take long for bernard to
rely on acquisitions to accelerate
growth over the next decade bernard
completed dozens of acquisitions ranging
from just a few million to a few billion
dollars despite the large number of
acquisitions each acquisition was
strategic and precise
each acquisition expanded operations
into new areas reduced overhead and
build up the company's high capacity
fiber optic network by 1995 ldds had
grown to being the country's fourth
largest long distance carrier and
bernard would rename the company
worldcom that same year
despite his massive success bernard was
a very quiet and religious man that
avoided the spotlight bernard was a
member of the east haven baptist church
in brookhaven mississippi and he was a
leading member of the church
he regularly attended church every week
and he even talked sunday goal
on top of this he named his four
children two of which are adopted
treasure ave joy and faith bernard would
also start every corporate meeting with
prayers
considering all of this bernard was
literally the last person you would
expect to be a fraudster he was adopting
children he was teaching sunday school
and it looked like he had extremely
strong morals and ethics and this was
the case up until 2000. there's no
evidence suggesting that bernard was
committing fraud before 2000. so his
entire rise up from running a struggling
phone company to running one of the
largest telecommunications businesses in
america was presumably completely
legitimate so what happened
well the answer seems to boil down to
just one thing greed the only step left
was for burner to overtake att but this
would prove to be his biggest challenge
bernard continued his strategy of
acquiring his way to the top in 1996 he
purchased mfs communications for 12
billion dollars which made worldcom a
global player
and though this was a great buy his next
move would leave wall street stunned in
1997 the second largest
telecommunications company mci
communications was looking for a merger
partner
but instead of offering to merge with
mci bernard offered to buy the entire
company for 29.4 billion this started an
intense bidding battle for mci but
bernard would prevail buying out mci for
37 billion dollars in september of 1998.
world to com was officially the second
largest telecommunications business in
america there were only one acquisition
away from overtaking atnt and this
acquisition would come in october of
1999. bernard had made a deal with
sprint ceo to acquire the company for
wait for it
129 billion dollars many news
publications actually reported the story
as if it was already completed and given
that both parties were in complete
agreement all the money was ready to go
and that they just had a couple of
formalities left the deal seemed to be
good as done but then uncle sam stepped
in in june of 2000 the doj sued to stop
the acquisition and that left the deal
dead in the water if the deal had gone
through worldcom would have comfortably
overtaken att in terms of market cap
their revenue would still slightly be
less than at t but given their worldcom
average 50 growth per year throughout
the 1990s it wouldn't take longer than a
year for worldcom to completely overtake
att
and that's exactly why the doj didn't
like the deal while this was a
disappointing setback it was still just
a matter of time until worldcom
naturally outgrew d so it seemed like
bernard had still come out on top but
then the dot-com bubble burst and the
bernard would resort to fraud
the dot-com crash killed the vast
majority of tech companies most of which
would never return
but i think it's pretty safe to assume
that worldcom was definitely in a
category of too big to fail if bernard
simply reported the losses as is
worldcom probably would have performed
like intel cisco and microsoft they
would have crashed 40 to 60 percent and
stalled out for several years but it's
very unlikely that they would have faded
into oblivion bernard's actions however
would ensure that the latter was the
case
as the dot-com crash rolled around
worldcom started losing billions per
quarter but bernard faked the financial
reports of the company and made it seem
like worldcom was actually making
billions wall street was pleasantly
surprised while att was scrambling at t
laid up tens of thousands of employees
in an attempt to cut losses and close
the gap to worldcom yet they couldn't
even get close
looking back this was a clear major red
flag but it probably wasn't as clear as
it was unfolding aside from faking
profits bernard was taking out loans in
his own name and the company's name in
order to afford all the losses
unfortunately for bernard he wasn't very
good at this and it didn't take long for
auditors and the media to catch on
in march of 2001 the wall street journal
drew attention to the massive amount of
loans bernard was taking out and the sec
got involved shortly after
about a year later bernard would be
ousted from worldcom and just a couple
of months after that rotcom would file
for the biggest bankruptcy ever
tens of thousands of employees lost
their jobs pension plans and 401k plans
evaporated and investors suffered
substantial losses
around the same time bernard would
address his church and say i just want
you to know you aren't going to church
with a crook you could say that these
were his famous last words
the icc would continue their
investigation over the next two years
and though bernard never admitted to the
crimes he would be found guilty on all
counts and he was sentenced 25 years in
prison in july of 2005. bernard spent
the next 14 years in prison but at the
end of 2019 one of his daughters was
able to convince the judge to release
burner early due to his deteriorating
health and dementia his daughter
definitely wasn't lying as bernard
passed away just two months later on
february 2nd 2020.
in the end bernard was actually a
stellar businessman who was able to
reach extraordinary heights
but eventually success and greed got to
his head and he was ordered to fraud
which rapidly destroyed his life if he
had played it safe it's likely that
worldcom would have been another
household name like atnt and verizon
but instead the only thing people know
about bernard today is that he
orchestrated the largest accounting
fraud in us history were you guys
familiar with worldcom comment that down
below
also drop a like if you agree that greed
is extremely dangerous
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you